that is a gorgeous dress you're wearing
oh
a Christmas Vacation the Oscar goes to
and the Oscar goes to the Oscar goes to
Michelle yo RR
Avatar the way of water Brendan phaser
[Music]
everything everywhere around it's this
month's birthday happy birthday
it's not my birthday my mama's up here
somewhere I don't know she'll scream
there she is so this is what the multi
looks like
to the academy
thank you so much thank you to the
academy thank you accordingly
our fellow nominees you guys are our
heroes this is weird thank you to the
academy for recognizing the superhero
that is a black woman to my brilliant
and beautiful wife Ani if all this shiny
stuff and tuxedos goes away I would just
love to do laundry and taxes with you
for the rest of my life
way just won an Oscar together good
point there is greatness in every single
person it doesn't matter who they are
they it's you have a genius that is
waiting to erupt you just need to find
the right people to unlock that thank
you so much to everyone who has unlocked
my genius dreams are something you have
to believe in I almost gave up on mine
to all of you out there please keep your
dreams alive
[Music]
thank you